Heather yeah that is a lot of lava and
fire and other things that could burn
you to death oh that's a trap that is
very very much a trial talking about new
guy what draw oh crap you weren't
kidding here we go
No
okay no I'm not the only one seeing that
we're running out of track right no good
Jessie that's rich now do it alarms
don't kill me now
Wow I thought something bad was going to
happen there but hey I guess
everything's gonna be whoa
okay Reuben remember when I said
everything was going to be just fine
before I know I was wrong then but I
have a very good feeling sucks whoa
well gasps are officially crossed off my
to see list done with the gas ever need
to see them
is it
is everyone okay I'm not dead I guess
that's pretty good ditto Duda they're
not dead I just can't believe that Petra
comes down here all the time this place
is awful your throats gonna be sore
later Axl why I'm just saying wasn't
that you doing all that screaming before
sounded like you were really shredding
your larynx we were just lucky to make
it out alive that's more than most
people can say their bones are probably
still sizzling away and not lava down
there Wow morbid sorry
can you throw up like inside your body
uh-huh I know because I just did about
five times